[Music]
somebody told me earlier i got a dm from
somebody like it was a big like big like
they were trying to help me out they
were trying to help me out going
i love that when they give you advice
yeah but they're helping me out they're
my buddies
he sends me uh i get i get a dm uh this
morning and you know how twitter is like
you know sometimes they'll be like
you'll get messages in your message
request that
i don't pay attention to them you know
uh
and this is the message i got please
stop covering brendan i'm dming you this
because i'm not trying to contribute to
the meme about it
seriously stop i wasted 45 minutes
thinking it would end on monday's
episode
okay
can
can i give a word of advice here sure
if you find yourself a self having to
say the phrase
i don't want to add to the meme of it
you're the living embodiment of the meme
yeah this message might have
this dm might as well have been sent
from [ __ ] bent pixels
um
buddy
i got an email from this guy named
b schwab
i don't know
well
because of that and i i will say that
you know
i will agree with this
we do cover shaab a lot
um people get annoyed it happens all the
time you don't cover them you don't
cover me cover and they go you cover
them too much so
here's what i have to say
when thick boy stops making me money
we'll [ __ ] stop covering them but
right now thick boys making me some cash
so guess what i found
we are making a couple tree bucks off
dick boy okay clips channels [ __ ] got
2000 since we've covered burning shop
again and this is true we've gained 2
000 new subscribers on the clip channel
that's not an insignificant that's a big
number right okay so big jump here's the
thing
um
brendan shop we could all agree
you're gonna love this guys i'm
it's only a 2 minute and 17 second clip
but it's worth it
brandon schaub decided you know what i
used up my 20 i was gonna say hour of
material but i forgot it was 25 minutes
i used my 25 minutes of material up
in five takes
so it's time to work on a new hour
special
so brennan was uh this is i think four
days ago was in portland
okay
he's working on some new material you
want to hear it
sure you guys want to hear a little bit
of the shopster all right here we go
shopmeister let's go i love portland man
portland's cool we're staying right
across the river down there in downtown
i've been here about three years a
little dicey yeah little dicey look
nicer
all right hello dicey huh
what what comic is he stealing this from
because every time he does a new gimmick
he's stealing it from a comic so we're
going to find out a couple weeks from
now that like todd todd barry does this
or something like there'll be another
comic be like hey man just to let you
know uh shop stole from todd barry
here's the [ __ ] clip of him doing the
same bid in 2009.
like jim gaff again yeah exactly he's a
little dicey it's a little dice you're
hey now
what's the thing he does he's doing the
voice
he does the other voice like hot pocket
he's doing it he's saying it's dicey
exactly saying it's dicey
his next joke his next joke is going to
be portland's dicey hamburger
oh my god
guys portland's a little dicey out there
am i right guys hey shucky ducky quack
quack
oh god of me
brendan
okay portland's cool we're staying right
across the river down there in downtown
i've been here about three years a
little dicey yeah a little dicey dicey
yeah yeah well dicey yeah what is that
it's his funny voice he's being funny
he's funny guy
i think he's copying honestly if i had
to guess he's he seems to be copying
like callan's delivery have you ever
seen brian callan stand up
if um
he kind of does that
lift the face uh
he makes facebook
he does these voices you think it's the
real people
he he reminds me of like you remember
when you were a kid and like you had
that one friend that like their dad
thought they were really funny but it
was yeah please leave me alone you're
trying to molest me
like that one yeah exactly
the one who knows too much hip lingo
yeah right hey what's up fellow kids
what up no cap
you're 16.
it's basically gotham city
what
it's like gotham city bro like batman i
have to see yeah because you know
remember when they filmed the dark
knight they filmed it in portland
couldn't afford to film a movie in
portland people either people either say
gotham city is either chicago or new
york that's it there's no other third
option you know you know what gotham
city is like vancouver
i like that they added graphics to it
[Applause]
[Music]
why are they clapping i don't even get
it
they're not like the cool guy it's
gotham city when bane took over
no no brendan brennan the problem with
you is
i never know what you're saying
no he's saying cause like when bane was
um
it was bad when bain was taken over
what
i'm trying to help you out so you're not
lost
so the dark knight rises was filmed in
london nottingham glasgow in portland
los angeles new york portland new york
and portland and portland so now
portland okay
pitts pittsburgh
pitts was it was it pittsburgh oregon a
suburb of portland
no okay then no
you think cte is your ally
i was born [ __ ]
molded by it
[Laughter]
you didn't know cte until you were a man
[Laughter]
oh well
what will happen if i review bomb your
special on imdb
it'll be painful
for you
was making two of the worst comedy
specials of all time part of your plan
of course
[Music]
[ __ ] [ __ ]
oh [ __ ]
[Laughter]
[Music]
you think government's your ally [ __ ]
eyes doing it doing the voice he's doing
the bit
by the way brian cowan is stuck in the
plane and he's like getting a seat belt
off and he's like no no they'll be
expecting one of us in the wreckage
brother
[Laughter]
gallon's like i didn't do anything
you think government's your ally
that's not a wow
we haven't seen this and we were [ __ ]
around and did a better pain band
anybody can do a bane right like that
you cover your mouth
entry level that's an entry-level
impression if you can't do impressions
yeah anyone should be able to do this
yeah that's the easiest one in the
[ __ ] biz
i was born in the ring
did he say he was born in the rain yeah
because portland portland's rainy yeah
i hate him
that was the funniest thing he could
think about portland is the rain
yeah not the you know
literal [ __ ] lockdown uh chad zones
where they broke up and formed their own
government and then auntie for shoots
black kids
remember that no
it was when they shot a bunch of black
kids in a car to be fair like oh god
they were scary black kids in a car to
be fair they did exactly what they
criticized the police for to be fair i
think it was raining though
oh that's right that's the joke
you're homeless different level you're
homeless
bro this coming from a guy that lives in
l.a
we could tell by your demeanor your
attitude your comedy
so are you going to do these on your
news special because i mean people
outside of portland may not get all
these great jokes i don't know i know i
could tell you this he's probably
scouting out the joe rogan's
neighborhood so he could be his neighbor
and he could come into the door like
creamer
how much do you want to bet right now
because rogan is building a comedy club
in austin
how much do you want to bet
that brennan's going to be like y'all
want to do a new special i want to do it
at your club in austin when you open it
up and joe's going to have to like
gently let him down nice way to dodge
him yeah that's a really good point oh
god you're right
because i just found out that rogan's
opening up a club is he really what that
makes you know austin honestly that's
not the uh the comedy mothership because
you know
bro like shrooms and space yeah i was i
was on his i was on his forum circa 2009
i know
yeah i'm willing to bet
good money that lauren pritchard shows
up at that [ __ ] place yeah with his
ghost baby
yep it is not frowned upon here it's all
honestly though like he bought like an
old historic theater in austin like he's
got the [ __ ] money he's got well i
literally just bought his old historic
like giant theater in austin right
building club it's like woof
dude is not frowned upon here it's all
good dude it's all good to be homeless
here i love it man i feel like these
kids graduate from like portland new or
portland state they get done he's doing
local humor
he's only doing local he's doing the
this is the humor that the host does
he's trying to cover yeah i know because
he's a local right that the note would
get the he would make it usually because
he's a local and because it is it's
warm-up material
it's like it's the easiest material to
do is get a host up there do a couple
local jokes and at 405 huh
sit on that long enough am i right
and then everybody's like oh i know that
that's familiar to me
portland you were poorly okay here's the
other thing he really he tried to
overreach with his local reference
because he named two schools for this
joke t well this joke doesn't work but i
get the kind of joke he's trying to do
you could just name one of the local
schools you know
state they get done and their buddies
like so what do you think it is like you
know i was going to use my engineer
degree and be an engineer or uh hold on
it's what degree
his engineer has engineered
engineer so here's here's what's
happening with chop
shop in his brain
measures comedy and like they're not
laughing this moment shop is it doesn't
understand when you do comedy that
sometimes you build up a joke right like
you build up to a joke
um
he's rushing through the not funny part
the part that weak in the bismarck they
call the setup
well what royce can i can i see the
problem with that is uh-huh so a lot of
times if you uh and i'm no expert here
no no no but um if you rush through the
setup
then when you get to the end i don't
know what you meant
oh that's a good point because they
didn't do the you know the important
part of the joke
he's just trying to go upstairs i'm a
friend of your engineer but let me guess
the joke's gonna be i haven't seen this
to the end obviously the joke's gonna be
oh i figured i'll just be homeless in
portland and then he'll make a joke
about rain again that's my guess
brendan is like the equip if brendan
writing jokes was like
a game of billiards
it's it's like the equivalent of going
up to a pool table and there's like four
balls left over on the table from the
last game and instead of like getting
all the balls on the table racking them
and then taking a shot you just walk up
and just throw a pool cue at the [ __ ]
table
four balls on it like that's there's
just no setup there's no you just
and you're like i don't know what just
happened but
i don't think that's how you play the
game use my engineer degree and be an
engineer my engineer degraded engineer
well what else would you use it for you
[ __ ] [ __ ] well he's about to tell
you
how much to be homeless man
okay there's the joke
oh yeah dude that's cool man
i eat some wagyu burger dan and finish
it
that was the joke whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa
that was the joke hey
buddy you're in portland you see those
things that they're doing the tours on
they're called segways they're not just
vehicles that you use to move around
portland but they help you move from
story to story to tell an interconnected
story when you're telling jokes
dude you also like
you you you're supposed to expand on
that right right build you build on it
like you you could make a joke about
like the student loan like how expensive
they are
or
or something
be like why do you think they have the
better joke this is not great because
it's not a great setup but why do you
think that the demilitarized zone was so
actually well kept and well behaved a
bunch of those homeless people were
engineers
something like that right
but instead what he does is he goes what
are you gonna be homeless anyway i ate a
burger the other day
[Laughter]
i was hungry
it's like it's like hanging out with
somebody who's not listening to you
while you guys are having a conversation
well it's like wayne's world uh-huh
uh-huh it's like it's like
it's like if you were telling somebody
yeah no i'm gonna be homeless next week
and they were like yeah so i had a
burger yeah you're like what the [ __ ]
bro i just told you i'm gonna lose my
home
not just a burger either like a wagyu
burger oh my god
he's like [ __ ] yeah i'm homeless
engineers right
so like i ate this 50 burger the other
day and then i threw out half of it
so i don't know if you know this or not
i'm rich virgie if you don't figure fix
your over modulation i'll kill you
myself
what do you think can you figure it out
quietly
yes thanks
[Laughter]
homeless man
oh yeah dude that's cool man
so the punchline was [ __ ] yeah that's
cool man yeah
so every brandon shop [ __ ] listen if
you don't merch i swear to god if you
don't let me hear about how delicious
this wagyu burger was you're gonna have
a problem with me
i eat some wagyu burger dad and finish
it i'm walking down downtown i was
dragging
a brioche buns
starts doing the bane voices i need him
everyday i didn't finish it i'm walking
down downtown walking down the street
let's get homeless dude skinny as [ __ ]
i'm like oh my man you're like starving
you want half this burger guys
see cause the homeless guy in portland
is also a vegan
what's the matter royce you look sad i
just
don't want to be accepted i don't want
to be around anymore
i won't be around this this is this this
this i said it was interesting
about the burger
hey hey brendan what does that do for
the greater good
[Applause]
hey brendan
brendan
say i have triples of the barracuda
otherwise the burger stuff isn't true
isn't true
tell the kid
she's going to be all right
brendan has brain damage but he's going
to get better
oh [ __ ]
i said you know what let me do some let
me give you some cash do you guys have
crypto
oh cause everyone in portland is a
hipster imagine if somebody did a show
five seasons of it that was about that
yeah you could call it like
portland land or something right right
and what if you got like a former snl
star to like just do it but like a
brilliant one right you know what i mean
like one who can really immerse himself
in characters like pete davidson
okay hear me out hear me out marsh
portlandia
but with pete davidson
remember when like guys like fred
armisen would be [ __ ] coos hounds oh
yeah he got a lot a [ __ ] for that too no
but remember when it made sense
right remember when you'd see like you'd
hear all these stories of fred armist
and getting [ __ ] and you'd go yeah but
that makes sense he's brilliant except
he's really funny talk his way into
yeah but like pete davidson i just still
don't understand it fred armistead must
have been the best one because gross
would be like wait you're not gay
like i guarantee he got a lot wait
you're not gay
she's like no and then i'm not gay i am
and guys like that always just
freebasing coke with him in his [ __ ]
place and he's just drinking us straight
out of a vodka bottle read the stories
about armisen the guy was all [ __ ]
hound yeah is a pussyhound and remember
when they meet him and all the metoo
stories were like you [ __ ] me and they
stopped talking to me
there was no stories of him actually
being inappropriate it was just him
pumping and dumping like every actress
but that's right
can i point something out there was
never a trash tuesday episode about fred
harmonson no
you know why you know why you know why
because none of them said no and they
actually blew him in his f-150
and he was funny yeah they were like
they're like oh yeah you're on snl yeah
i'll blow you in your truck
dude there was like two dozen stories
that came out during me too and they
were all like yeah he had sex with me
and didn't tell me he was married they
ghosted me and you're like
yeah he sounds pretty cool he'll be like
hey can we hang out with
foreign characters if you hang out with
him he's just kicking back a [ __ ]
beer like yeah bro these [ __ ] slots
dude he's stealing it's little jail yeah
here's some cash dude
different vibe
it's a different vibe
yeah did you hear that yeah yeah i want
to [ __ ] him yeah that's why we're here
that's why it's mostly women when your
brain is like i sell these places out
it's broads mostly they kind of want to
[ __ ] them you know what i mean and and
dude bros that don't realize that their
girl actually was willing to come with
them because they're going to probably
[ __ ] brendan schaub in his truck yeah
exactly
portland's white
huh royce where you going
where you going royce we got a show to
do
royce we're doing the show
we got to do the show
i'm back hey virgi i'm sorry i was mean
to you earlier you don't deserve it i
was just angry at brendan
i don't know if you know this virgie but
portland's pretty white
i just found out
i just found out i just found out
it's as white as those antifa guys that
shot those black kids in the car and
jazz
i'm not letting that go i'm not letting
go of the fact that you guys used police
brutality against blacks as a pretense
to take over
and it took you one week to be so scared
of some black teenagers in a car that
you lit them up with ar-15s
[Laughter]
and then nobody did anything about it
i think that might have happened on
george floyd boulevard too
and then antifa's getting
antifa is getting interviewed by unicorn
riot and they're just like yeah you know
turns out uh you know black teenagers in
a car at night pretty [ __ ] scary
makes us all jump the gun a little bit
sorry about that
the whitest city in america
portland is a white person's wakanda
that's that's that's not true brandon
because portland exists
salt lake city is white people's wakanda
can he make a joke without a movie
reference you could you could have
stopped just after the joke part of that
sentence and i would have agreed with
you no
but you're telling me it's whiter than
salt lake city
it's whiter than jackson hole
all of new hampshire
yes
vermont that city yeah
exactly why i think new hampshire and
vermont are like the white lesbians
wakanda
it's just filled with a bunch of pt
cruisers and bowling alleys
lesbian mufasa talking to lesbian simba
what part's that oh no that's the trans
neighborhood we don't go over there
do you know what you call a large group
of lesbians in a crowd um what
a flannel it's a flam it's a flannel of
lesbians okay
he just wrote that backstage bro off the
dome son he spits off the dome and
everybody knows that
everybody knows that about brendan they
call him brendan the improv king shop
i want to see like a showcase
like of comedians but i want brandon
shop to have to go up in between like
dave chappelle and louis ck oh can you
imagine
oh
the difference is if they go to stab
bren and no one jumps up to protect him
they just let him get stabbed
[Laughter]
all you see is chappelle in the back on
the phone with rogan yo man
your [ __ ] getting stabbed on stage
right now oh is he bombing again no no
they're stabbing him
i'm i'm not getting in the way
so
and it's not even a crowd member it's
like donnell rawlings stabbing him i was
gonna say be like yeah it's not even a
trans person it's just a george
mossvidal fan seems to not like him he
[ __ ] stabbed him by the way somebody
in the chat said can he write yeah
brendan writes bits in the back but he
writes like charlie kelly
it's like pictures and like weird things
it looks like a [ __ ] goonies treasure
map
[Applause]
here it is i have it i have it i you
know what somebody leaked i have it
right here somebody leaked brendan's
brendan's joke book do you want to see
it
is that a napkin
what is that from that's charlie the way
charlie writes oh that's right okay
there you go uh listen i actually have i
actually have somebody his notebook that
he wrote gringo poppy on
denim
chicken denim chicken
oh
so yeah i'm not gonna we are not gonna
stop covering um right now no we're
gonna keep doing it more and more is
there more i need more that's buddy if i
had more i need more i need more brendan
in my life buddy if i had more just
despite whoever that person was buddy if
i had more brendan do you not understand
that's all i would be playing
um no but that's that's the only clip i
have i guess that was released that was
filmed by the um
by the comedy club
why yeah
like why did it happen
no why would they want people to know it
happened
because they want to file a [ __ ] dude
yeah they want to file an insurance
claim for the bomb that went off in
their [ __ ] building